i'm here with rook and we are going to  what's up school's name it's very long  so flow so what they said it the longest  name be so full eco :  does they keep going after that because  i feel like it does so follow  ikura team oh cool we raise money over  the past month all the guests sores and  raised over 10k euros gonna help out the  kids and make them have an awesome place  to learn and to get educated which is so  so important  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  the walls  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  what's really sweet is this one there in  the red shirt takes care of the girl in  the picture and guides our around  everywhere computer noises thank you  [Music]  [Applause]